some people on the internet have decided
they don't like you it's not just your
your speech on that one topic they're
going to go after they're going to find
anything they can and and sometimes they
even can do guilt by association to
basically delegitimize you having any
any further opinion we talk about um the
great untruths what doesn't kill you
makes you weaker always trust your
feelings and uh life is a battle between
good people and evil people and we ince
the fourth one in this book which is
simply no bad person has any good
opinion because if you'll notice a lot
of the way we we're not actually trying
to figure out is this argument true or
right we're trying to make an argument
that this is a bad person and therefore
you don't have to listen to
them all right guys bang bang I've got
Greg here with me Greg I thought a great
place to start is free speech is
Paramount to a democracy really kind of
thriving um and the best way I know to
describe the importance of free speech
is free speech is all about letting the
people you disagree with still have a
voice voice and it feels like fire as an
organization has been very focused on
supporting not only those you agree with
but also maybe those you don't agree
with and so talk a little bit as to how
do you unpack what is a free speech
issue versus what may be something else
because I think we need to kind of
Define Free Speech issues before we
start talking about the cancelling of
the American mind the coddling of the
American mind what's going on on
campuses
today great question yeah and and there
was it was kind of funny like the LA
Times had had a piece saying fire only
defends opinions it agrees with and it's
like well then I guess we agree with all
opinions um because we defend people all
over the political spectrum and what's
funny is we also couldn't decide who we
agree with because the the one of the
goals of the staff and we've maintained
it really well is to have actual
political diversity in who works for the
staff if anything we you know we don't
have enough conservatives um in in uh in
leadership for example we we really do
try to be a place where people who vote
for different candidates actually work
together in common cause and we have
been since
1999 um so free speech I I'm a big
believer in uh I'm a First Amendment
lawyer I I specialized in First
Amendment and I think you can draw a lot
of wisdom from the First Amendment even
in situations where you're not talking
about government suppression of speech
so there are lots of like really smart
principles decided by some of you know
some of the smartest people in American
history people like Oliver Wendell
Holmes and Lou Louis brandise and Robert
Jackson um and so some of the parameters
are you know what's the purest kind of
uh clearest example of freedom of speech
I would call that a mere expression of
opinion that that that essentially
saying this is what I think this is my
preference etc etc and the big uh rule
that runs all the way through First
Amendment law is a Prohibition against
Viewpoint discrimination which is and
that means that if you're uh like if you
have a forum and you're allowing
everyone to talk except for the people
who disagree with you on macroeconomics
um or very more more specifically people
who have a a point of view on a
particular policy um that's considered
to be the not allowable in a public
forum under the law but also kind of a
bad idea in general because it it makes
it the uh Marketplace of ideas unfair it
makes the the playing field unfair it
also helps you unpack things about like
what is harassment what isn't harassment
what's a threat what isn't a threat um
and we've actually given how nasty
things have gotten on campus we've
actually had quite a workout going
through these fact patterns lately
because uh since the attacks on the
horrible attacks by himas on October 7th
we're seeing actual threats um on campus
more often than we're used to we're
seeing actual harassment or Flatout
discrimination um so I think that
there's a lot of wisdom that the law can
bring to bear but one thing that makes
fire different we we were the foundation
for individual rights in education until
2022 and then we rebranded as the
foundation for individual rights and
expression to indicate that we now
litigate off campus we now have a much
wider um a goal and one of them is to
get people to appreciate not just the
first amendment but free speech culture
and we we always try to you know answer
what is what are the Norms of free
speech culture they come back to sort of
older fashioned idioms like Everyone's
entitled to their opinion it's a free
country all these things that indicate
that we used to have a better sense that
you are entitled to your opinion even if
even if I hate your
guts now when you see this um maybe
degradation of that belief set
what's driving it right you write in the
first book that uh you put together or
the first book I read uh that you guys
put together the coddling of the
American mind it feels like whether it's
parents whether it is school whether it
is just people in society they basically
said wow the world's a really bad place
there's all kinds of craziness out there
why don't we protect our children from
having to experience this which as a
parent you feel like that's a that's a
good idea right it's I'm going to
protect my kid from bad things uh but
you guys really unpack and say by
coddling the minds of these children you
actually maybe have done more damage
than help and so unpack a little bit as
to like good intentioned people may have
had this really negative impact that
they still might not even be really
aware of yet yeah well to back up a
little bit about where has the um you
know censorship Instinct come from how
how have things gotten worse and I
always like to remind people that and
there's a reason why I call my uh suback
the eternally radical idea because
that's a reference Free Speech itself
because in every generation uh young
people old people stand up to demand
censorship and they're usually the ones
who win um it's actually comparatively
historically rare to have a period um
like we've had for you know 50 years
where uh there is at least nominal
support for freedom of speech and I feel
very lucky to have grown up in the 80s
and 90s where the Free Speech law was
getting much better but certainly for
someone you know on on the left uh it
was the defining characteristic of being
being on the left at least in the 80s
and 90s was being pro uh Pro freedom of
speech um but we're regressing more to
the historical mean which is if you
don't have these cultural norms that
actually remind you of how valuable free
speech is there's a tendency to kind of
regress into this idea yeah but words
hurt um it's not like we just discovered
this we always knew this um but the
response was yeah that's true but it's
better than fighting things out in the
normal way we actually resolve disputes
historically which is violence or the
threat of Ence um and that's one of the
reasons why things like sticks and
stones may break my bones but names will
never hurt me was such a wise thing to
teach kids and it's been reinterpreted
by uh people on campus as if we now just
discovered that words can actually hurt
it's like no that that's nonsense you
didn't need this little saying for for
kids if words didn't hurt the saying
wouldn't even make sense but what we
were trying to do was to teach kids
something to reflect on when words hurt
to make them hurt less and believe me
all of us who grew up with that it
helped it helped in situations um that
that you're like yeah you know I'm the
bigger person I ignore it so when it
comes to uh cobbling the American mind
um that was my my first book with
Jonathan height um my first book was
actually one called unlearning Liberty
which I wrote in 2012 which pointed out
that hey guys I think things are about
to get a lot worse um and unfortunately
we are right uh but codling the American
mind has a kind of weird idea that
essentially the same things that were
now threatening academic freedom and
Free Speech are the kind of mental
habits that will also make people young
people anxious and depressed and we
first talked about this in 2014 uh when
both cancel culture and the um the new
Norms on campus really became clear and
it it was not subtle 24 there was
something very different for those of us
who work on campus between 2014 and say
2012 just because students had always
been great on freedom of speech and then
suddenly they weren't but in coddling we
focus a lot more on how I believe that
parents uh K through 12 uh higher ed
culture in general is teaching um young
people what are called cognitive
distortions in cognitive behavioral
therapy and I know as someone who
struggled with anxiety and depression my
whole life and actually being
hospitalized for it is one of the things
that ultimately led to coddling of the
American mind that if you have too many
cognitive distortions in your in your
brain you're going to be miserable um
and what are cognitive distortions
they're kind of mental exaggerations
things like overgeneralizing um
catastrophizing binary thinking
believing that you understand the future
you know the future and of course you
assume you're going to be doomed all of
these uh kind of things that for those
of that I've had great success in
training my brain to not take quite as
seriously to sort of respond to as
exaggerated thoughts which they really
are but what what we were arguing was it
seemed as if students showing up on
campus in 2014 2015 had already been
taught a lot of these catastrophized in
emotional reasoning kind of ideas that
would make them miserable it would also
be a big threat to ecademic freedom and
Free Speech but it would have the side
effect of making the people who believe
this ideology uh depressed and anxious
and unfortunately um when we wrote the
article initially in the Atlantic in
2015 we thought we'd see a little
scholarly dip in mental health among
young people you know like something
that you could point to not not
necessarily the most dramatic effect and
man things got so much worth both for
free speech and academic freedom on
campus uh and for mental health um and
you know it's one of those things that
height and I usually when people point
out that we were precient in this we say
well we really wish we weren't right so
on the book uh the subtitle is how good
intentions and bad ideas are setting up
a generation for failure this book's
been out for a long time uh is an
incredible read but also has done very
well uh from a selling standpoint um on
the back cover it says Michael Bloomberg
has a quote and Rising intolerance foros
opposing viewpoints is a challenge not
only on college campuses but also in our
national political discourse the future
of our democracy requires us to
understand what's happening and why now
the reason why that is such an
interesting quote is because that
basically describes exactly what has
occurred in politics not only on college
campuses but at the national level over
the last call it three to you know eight
years depending on what timelines you
want to look at and so to me it is very
difficult to solve problems if you
cannot have conversations with people
who don't have opposing views and so
that leads us then to the second book
which is the cancelling of the American
mind and when I look at that it's almost
like hey if you're coddled and you don't
like other people's views then how do
you respond you can ignore them or you
can cancel them and it feels like many
many people have been trained to go
after the cancelling mechanism versus
the ignoring mechanism and so describe a
little bit kind of the work and the
analysis that went into the can cing of
the American mind sure uh the cancelling
of the American mind is is very much a
followup to codling of the American mind
um I I co-authored it actually with a
now 23-year-old named Ricky Schlott
partially um we decided to co-author
partially because she's brilliant and
she and we're a very good team but also
because um so much of coddling was about
uh threats to the mental health of genen
Z young women and so co-authoring the
next piece with a jenzy young woman um
seemed to be just a common sense height
wrote the forward to to cancelling of
the American mind and but it does
usually help to you know be familiar
with one uh to there was a review that
was um somewhat critical of some of the
stuff we left out of cancelling the
American mind and it basically listed
all the things that we cover in cing in
the American mind so I was kind of like
yeah that's because you didn't read the
first one um uh and one thing we talk
about um uh we talk about in coddling
the American mind is this idea of moral
dependency um that essentially we teach
young people now at a level that we
didn't used to that if you have an
interpersonal squabble you know that you
go to an adult and that makes sense for
some kind of particularly severe ones um
like bullying for example or you know as
often happened to you know as kids you
get punched in the face um I I probably
got punched in the face more than most
and and I didn't always deserve it to be
clear um the uh that that uh they but
they don't let up on this idea in high
school and and they continue it in so in
high school it can be you know a special
Department in colleges it's the biased
resp response team it's administrators
who are there to sort of inter intervene
and by the time they get to corporations
these Norms are embedded in Human
Resources departments which have become
a major problem for a lot of companies
um if Human Resources sees itself as
essentially antagonistic to the to the
purpose of the organization which un
fortunately sometimes it really does so
I think that this moral kind of
dependency uh issue is part of the
problem I also think uh something that
happened and this is one of the real
wonderful things about writing with
someone so young is that our definition
of cancel culture is the uptick around
2014 and accelerating uh 2017 and after
of campaigns to get people punished
expelled fired deplatformed uh for
speech that would be protected by First
Amendment there what we mean we explain
this more in an appendix because it was
a little bit too in the weeds we mean as
an analogy to Public Employee law
another way to work in a great deal of
nuance into a short definition I think
short definitions are important and the
culture of fear and Conformity that
results you know from uh from that
uptick and I think the uh one of the
most interesting things that Ricky had
to say about this was that yes we talk
about it really hitting the world around
2014 which is around when Gen Z starts
hitting higher ed in large numbers but
she essentially grew up with cancel
culture this way of arguing Without
Really arguing of just uh morally
grandstanding making sure the your
opponent's life is miserable and that
they're a social Pariah without
convincing anybody that you're right or
they're wrong you just scare them or
eliminate them and this is very much a
junior high school kind of tactic and
unfortunately it feels like this junior
high school way of arguing is now
everywhere you look and about a third of
the book is focused on on all of the
forgive the expression BS ways we
currently argue both on the right and
the left uh that prevent us from ever
getting close to truth seeking uh
because if you if your argument is
primarily a system after system for
dismissing People based on their
identity also known as ad homm based on
their personal identity um you you're
wasting a tremendous amount of time and
you actually there there's no reason why
even even if the person you're arguing
with is a despicable person um that
doesn't mean the wrong and just because
someone is good or at least in your eyes
good doesn't doesn't at all relate to
the fact whether or not they're they are
right so a lot of the book is trying to
argue both there's this dysfunctional
way we argue that will get us nowhere
less than nowhere really and it's very
cruel in the meantime but there's
another way to there's another way to
argue and by the way we can actually
solve things if we argue in this other
way now the issue I see in
many of the ARG I'm gonna use Twitter as
kind of a really watered down bad
version of a mirror to society but it
definitely shows how people are
communicating and interacting with each
other is most people can't separate idea
from person yes and then they don't know
how to engage with an idea in a way that
could be respectful to the person but
also attack the idea and so there's
almost two components like first
separating out idea from person and then
second being able to engage with an idea
in almost I describe it as like a
gentlemanly way like there's a way to
you know I don't know if you think back
to like uh European old movie right or
maybe like kind of the the late 1800s
early 1900s when everyone has a
three-piece suit on and and they're
talking for sure but they're doing
it in a very respectful almost uh it's
harder to do it that way than just be
like you're a shut up you know
cancel you and so is it laziness that is
playing into some of this is it a lack
of intellectual um maybe training or or
uh preparedness like like what is
driving this where to argue with someone
in a high level sophisticated way takes
almost more effort and it takes more
respect for the art of arguing than just
yelling and screaming at each other like
Hooligans you know trying to cancel each
other today's episode is brought to you
by trust and will I've gone through a
number of different changes in my life
over the last few years I got married I
had a kid and I had to start thinking
about how could I ensure that my wife
and my child would be okay if anything
ever happened to me that's where trust
wheels and estate planning come into
play now most people what they do is
they get introduced to a friend an uncle
or someone in their local community it
tends to be someone who's really
expensive a lawyer an accountant or
somebody who does Estate Planning and
they just simply are using a one-size
fits-all template and just telling you
pay me thousands of dollars and I'll use
the same thing for you as the guy down
the street but that's not what trust and
will does they have a trusted online
estate planning product that starts as
low as
$159 which allows you to now protect
your legacy from the comfort of your own
home leverage their excellent customer
support available via phone email or
chat they have thousands of five-star
reviews and a rating of excellent on
trust pilot it takes most people 20 to
30 minutes to complete their estate plan
with trust and will and not only that
but if you go to trustand will.com pomp
you'll get 10% off plus you'll get free
shipping of all your your estate
planning documents so go to trustand
will.com Pomp and make sure you get an
estate plan in place whether is for you
or one of your loved ones having a trust
Andor a will can literally be the
difference between someone being taken
care of and someone not go check them
out today at trustand will.com pomp yeah
well I mean it there's so many different
factors that caus that and one again
once again it's kind of the regression
to the mean problem you have to learn
how to how to argue well um and it
requires a lot of lessons it requires a
lot of uh knowing a lot of different
rules that young people simply aren't
taught so to to some degree they can be
forgiven for simply never have been
taught this and the most horrifying
example that didn't make it into the
book um because it was only starting to
become clear how bad it had gotten is
how literal debate teams are now using
um ad homm Dodges and basically what we
call in the book The Perfect rhetorical
Fortress to win actual formal debates um
which is which is insane there's one
going around um you know about just uh
just you know basically making the the
whiteness of your opponent to be the
major issue in a debate um as opposed to
actually addressing say the topic uh
that you were you were supposed to
debate um so there there even the
institutions that should be teaching
people how to argue towards truth are
not they're actually to some degree at
least in some examples teaching this uh
this cancel culture way of arguing so
they're they're not taught it also
frankly that practice is harder um and
you and you might not win uh and since a
lot of people we we grow up in
increasingly
isolated uh spheres now made worse by
social media but physically also uh
America is more divided by politics but
also by class economic class than we
were say 30 40 years ago and this can
create a problem where you essentially
haven't encountered people who disagree
with you and you've more or less learned
that people who disagree with me are
stupid or evil um and that's a typical
assumption there there was a great line
from an evolutionary biologist saying in
the ancestral environment you pretty
much only ever met someone you really
disagreed with about fundamental matters
at the tip of a spear which is true um
so you have to learn these ways of of
produ productively arguing but why would
you when there's this easier out um
point out you know hey guess what I just
looked up something I found out and this
is called offense archaeology you wrote
well I'm arguing with you about a
contentious issue say affirmative action
or something like that oh wow I just
found this offensive thing you wrote in
your high school yearbook um and then
you're a bad person so I don't have to
listen to you anymore and and we go
through example after example of this
which is one of the reasons why I got so
depressed writing the book um is because
I already have a little bit of a Target
on my back for writing coddling the
American mind you know um mostly from
people who haven't read it they they
basically think the book is just saying
people are spoiled and it's like no
that's just the title um the the which
I've never liked the book is about
actually the harm that adults are doing
to younger people um but uh the idea of
getting a even bigger Target on my back
having gone through all these stories in
which once uh it's some people on the
internet have decided they don't like
you it's not just your your speech on
that one topic they're going to go after
they're going to find anything they can
um and and sometimes they even can do
guilt by association um one of the
tactics we talk about in the book that
both right and left use um that uh to
basically delegitimize you having any
any further opinion and that's one of
the reasons why just like in coling of
the American mind we talk about um the
great untruths these These are basically
ideas that uh are dysfunctional that
they go against um ancient wisdom and
modern psychology and will make you
miserable if you believe them so the the
first three were what doesn't kill you
makes you weaker always trust your
feelings which is sounds nice but it's
terrible advice um the uh and uh life is
a battle between good people and evil
people and we ince the fourth one in
this book which is simply no bad person
has any good opinion um and then in
parenthesis and everybody's arguably bad
because if you'll notice a lot of the
way we debate we're not actually trying
to figure out is this argument true or
right we're trying to make an argument
that this is a bad person and they for
you don't have to listen to
them so when people come on the podcast
sometimes uh they're very heels dug in
and whether people who listen agree or
disagree yeah one of my favorite
questions to ask these people is like
say something positive about the other
side what is one thing you agree with
them on the other side and so politics
is really simple if you have a hardcore
Democrat right ask them what is one
thing you agree with the Republicans on
vice versa um it always surprises me the
people who I already thought were highly
intelligent can rattle off tons of
things that they agree with with the
other side yeah the people who I'm
always like H this is an interesting
person but I'm not sure that the
horsepower might be there in the same
way that maybe others uh are they can't
or they refuse to yeah and it's this
very interesting Dynamic of like you
know there there's the old saying of um
you need to be able to argue the other
side better than you uh they can in
order to actually argue well actually
being able to identify what are the
areas of common ground and in politics
you see this politicians are actually
very good at being able to kind of
Grease these disagreements and basically
understand okay we might disagree on
geopolitical you know decision in a
certain region but here's all the other
things we agree with let's let's figure
this out and we as a society Point ah
there's politicians they're trying to
please everyone that that's their job or
whatever but they actually do get a lot
of stuff to a point where at least
there's a conversation you don't see for
the most part again there are some uh
nastiness still in politics and stuff
like that but for the most part you
don't see as much cancelling in politics
because you also know that person is not
going away that person is still gonna be
here in that job for the next two four
eight years you know whatever it ends up
being and so you got to figure out how
to work with them because cancelling
isn't really an option this is really
funny um the I lived in DC uh before
moving to I went to Stanford for law
school and then I lived up in San
Francisco as long as I could and I I
worked at the ACLU and you know all my
my my my friends were kind of like the
Burning Man artc crowd um but one thing
I didn't like about San Francisco even
in the late 90s at least the circles I
was in is that political arguments were
kind of lame because it was mostly
either we agree or we agree but you
don't go far enough um whereas in DC you
know you could have a great argument
with a cabbie kind of like and I had
some of my best you know because people
understood that it could actually be
kind of fun it could be it should be
friendly um and actually you know even
doing The Devil's Advocate thought
experimentation approach where even if
you don't actually disagree it's like
well let me try let me try this one on
you know that that can actually be great
and I and I felt like the way uh we
argued in the backyards at least in the
circles iow was in in San Francisco is
increasingly become the way we argue
everywhere and that's one thing that I
really do love about fire commitment to
genuine political diversity within staff
it keeps us honest um I mean I'm a you
know I'm a left leaning atheist
and believe me I have had my Minds
changed on a number of things by you
know right-leaning Evangelical
Christians including when I started at
fire by the
way having to you know painfully realize
that the most open-minded person on
staff was someone who was a
self-described Evangelical Christian she
she she had no problem with us going out
and you know uh tossing back some drinks
and arguing about the existence to God
like it was it was really like and I
realized I had stereotypes myself
yeah and I I think and in terms of kind
of like what I see you know what I
personally see as strengths on people on
the other side it's always hard for me
to figure out what the other side is
because the book takes on both the right
and the left when it comes to cancel
culture I definitely you know the the
overall look for um social justice of
course is something I agree with I do
think that uh cancel culture and the
tactics of argumentation that we tend to
use on the left prevent a lot of things
that could otherwise be f
I think we there's a certain kind of
doom doom and gloom and hopelessness um
on the left that actually we talk about
cing the American mind that prevents us
from fixing things um when it comes to
uh on the right you know I don't blame
them for being mad at Elites I don't
blame them at being mad higher education
in fact we talk about the rhetorical
Fortress um as as the sort of way of
avoiding arguments on the right and
they're very quick to you know you can
dismiss anybody that you can label a
liberal or woke you can you don't have
to listen to experts journalists even if
they're conservative or for the very
hard right you know anyone who disagrees
with Trump meanwhile we've spent a lot
of the book talking about how experts
have done themselves uh no favors still
I think anything that prevents you from
uh actually listening to people you
disagree with is not healthy for the
production ideas and certainly not for
solving
problems one of the chapters in the book
The cancelling of the American mind is
all about keeping your organization or
Corporation out of the culture wars and
you know there's a lot of people who run
Tech startups large corporations that
are decision makers at these companies
who listen to this podcast um I spend
quite a bit of time thinking about and
trying to kind of talk through uh these
ideas of uh the culture worlds are going
to happen whether you participate or not
yeah but you do have an option as to
whether to participate or not whether or
not you want to be a combatant correct
and so explain a little bit as to how
you think Business Leaders could stay
out of these and keep their employees
focused on the work on the product on
Revenue you know on kind of the
capitalistic Pursuit that they have been
entrusted with doing versus going ahead
and actually you know being that
combatant in the culture War oh man yeah
no that that's a chapter that I think a
lot about and and initially the the the
first version of that I wrote a
co-authored with height um I'm going to
start with something that I I that
should have been in there um uh more
prominently which I've been thinking
about a lot recently you have to make
sure you're not hiring counsellors in
the first place and what I mean by that
are the kind of employees who will show
up and uh believe it's sort of their
politics are the highway that
essentially the organization has to
publicly take stances I agree with and
by the way if it turns out that
absolutely brilliant um asy it person
that I have um if they say something you
know vaguely right-wing that they have
to be fired um and that's something that
you saw really hitting corporations
around 2018 as Generation Z started
graduating from from higher ed and it's
something that after C because codling
came out in the book The Original
article was 2015 the book came out in
2018 immediately height and I got emails
and phone calls from Business Leaders
all over the country saying yeah we have
a real problem with a new crop of
employees um they want me to fire so and
so and and a lot of the cancel culture
cases even some that didn't make the
book were lower levels sometimes new
higher employees demanding um that you
know you get rid of um
Antonio Martinez Garcia like there there
there are a couple people um that where
it was very clearly it's just lower
level employees demanded I can't work
with that person because in that case he
wrote a um a fairly racy bestselling
fiction book several years before which
is just just a crazy reason to to to
deny yourself talent and so you got to
make sure you're not handling can hiring
counselors in the first place a good way
to do that is to one hire older people
I talked to someone who has who's
running a startup in Silicon Valley and
he said we you avoid this problem I was
like how do you avoid this problem um
everyone we hire is 40 or older and I
like okay that will probably mostly uh
keep you say but he said doesn't
exclusively keep keep them away from
that um when it comes to uh saying at
the outset listen my organization
doesn't take political stances we we're
not that kind of organization we want to
have an office where people who vote for
whomever can work together and we don't
want politics to interfere with that we
make widgets like we're not also a
political organization and the kind of
employee who might be turned off by that
uh you know it might mean that there are
there are some great employees who would
want that but I do think you're probably
better off having someone to be like no
I get that I can I can compartmentalize
that that that's cool uh we thought what
coinbase did was interesting um you know
and saying that they don't take
political um positions and what's
interesting especially about that is
something like 5% of the staff actually
took the uh took the severance package
because they didn't want to work in an
environment that didn't to make uh take
political positions but think about that
that's the 5% that actually um led to a
lot of the problems in 2020 2021 and to
this day saying that I can't work with
people I disagree with um I can't be in
an office in which the boss doesn't uh
parrot kind of my political opinions um
that's probably avoiding a much bigger
headache and allowing the other 95% to
focus on their you know on their on
their jobs so I think you definitely
need to make sure that HR is on your
side I think having a policy saying like
listen we don't take political positions
I think that hiring from non-elite
schools or people even with with um
non-traditional um uh credentials uh is
going to be increasingly important I
think there are lots of ways to prove
you're smarter and hardworking um that
that are actually better signals than
graduating from Stanford or Harvard um
these days I think there's lots of ways
to to show that now and I hope there
will be more ways to show that um and I
think that uh oh and as far as something
to avoid the these um uh they're called
talkbacks uh at a lot of offices and
I've I've heard horror stories about
this um you know particularly in law
firms where a and I think the law firm
example was someone said was a was a
Christian um and she uh supported the
anti- um abortion decision um and when
the entire firm was planning to take a
public stance condemning uh the the
overturning of roie Wade she actually
said actually I agree with the
overturning of roie Wade um and they did
a talk back which happened all the time
um which is essentially
just you get yelled at by the younger
employees and some some of the other
ones who agree with them um it's not a
it's not a talk back at all and I'm like
it's always going to be more effective
if you talk to people individually
rather than having these weird
ceremonies and I call them ceremonies
because I I talked to one of my one of
my awesome employees who's a former law
firm uh guy himself and he's like no no
we know what the drill is with talkbacks
talkbacks are you know you aren't
actually talkbacks you just get yelled
at for your lack of political Conformity
so I don't have those when you have
certain people inside the company
they're employees you can you know try
to uh address them in a multitude away
some of what you're highlighting here
how do you deal with it if it is your
customers yeah or external so people who
are obviously involved in the business
you're dependent on them to some degree
but they pressure and you see this both
with customers and investors a lot of
times how how does some of what you've
described here change or evolve in that
scenario this episode is brought to you
by aradon they are a brand new startup
led by a number of Silicon Valley
Legends who just raised $81 million to
build the future of Internet
infrastructure you're probably wondering
what that means let me explain there are
numerous new disrup Ive technologies
that are being adopted simultaneously
from blockchain to artificial
intelligence to zero knowledge
Technologies in order to ensure that
these Technologies thrive in this new
world we need new infrastructure and
that is where arine comes in they just
launched their first product line called
Tera flux which is a Bitcoin miner
powered by the world's first 4 nanometer
silicon chip technology these aircooled
single-phase end dual phase emerging
cooling miners have unrivaled speed and
efficiency they've Superior uptime and
they leverage a brand new innovation
called Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
idine.com that's a a d ne.com go check
them out at idine.com today yeah I do
think that there's an opening for
particularly if it's um
consistently enforced uh an idea of like
we're politically neutral we don't take
political positions if you stick to it
early and often I think a lot of
investors that otherwise might be very
you know Pro you know spout spout my
particular point of view would respect
that and I think that's going to be
happening more often so I think there
there is an opening to take that
position that um investors uh and
clients might actually uh come come
around to respecting uh but you have to
stick with it and you have to be you
know clear and I think that the past
three weeks have made some companies
aware of the downside of of taking
political positions uh you saw a lot of
universities that took political
positions on every other thing um be
worried about taking a position
condemning the Hamas attacks um and of
course that made them look terrible
because that it's like so really like on
on much tougher issues you took you took
really resounding opinions and on this
one which seems fairly clearcut at least
the initial attacks certainly did um
you're not willing to really say
anything uh so I I think that there
might be better awareness of the the
benefits of political neutrality I think
of course if you have an investor who
really wants to sort of micromanage you
know the political positions you take
that's a kind of a problem and and I
think this is one of the reasons why
people object to um e some of the ESG
movement because it does oftentimes
recommend things that uh kind of would
normally be seen as as um exceeding kind
of the the appropriate bounds and
sometimes they will recommend stuff that
actually there's research on so so um
one thing that that some of the
investors I know uh really like to push
um and have learned that they shouldn't
is um some of the uh Dei consultant
stuff but there's research on Dei
consultants and there's research on a
lot of this programming and a lot of it
doesn't just not work it actually can
increase tension among students from
different among employees from different
backgrounds so I think that you know you
if you uh if you have an investor who
wants to dictate this kind of stuff to
you be you know be ready to argue argue
back to basically be able to show
evidence that that essentially some of
these things you're recommending aren't
actually helping um you might lose some
in the process but uh once investors get
the idea that they can sort of
politically run you as well um that's
not necessarily someone you want to do
business
with what's been the most surprising
part as you really kind of understood
and began to uh break down what's
happening what what what has surprised
you most well in some ways it wasn't as
much of a surprise because I've been
working on campus for 22 years so by the
time I started writing this I knew that
the problem was really bad um the I I am
kind of
surprised uh you like there was a a
recent review of the book in the
dispatch that um
basically you know made the argument
that um onethird of Americans saying
they're either very or a little worried
about um cancel culture was a minuscule
number and it's like I don't think you
know a lot about the history of freedom
of speech like it in like pure in
McCarthyism for example in the heart
height of McCarthyism uh 9% of
professors said that they were
self-censoring um they were censoring
their work I want to be clear that's
almost one in 10 that's really really
bad to have one in 10 academics saying
that they are
self-censoring um and that's one of the
high watermarks you've ever gotten in
polling of professors saying they're
self-censoring so someone who could
actually look at the data and be like oh
that's only onethird and only only 10%
are saying they're very worried it's
like you don't have a grasp of this very
very well so like people's lack lack of
of understanding about what the various
numbers mean continues to Blow Me Away
um for example like how confident people
are saying that you know we we talk
about uh so just to go quickly through
the stats there's uh we document about a
thousand attempts to get professors
fired about two-thirds of them um uh
succeed in some uh sorry fired or
otherwise punished uh about two-thirds
of them succeed in getting them punished
in some way um I always point out that
onethird of those actually come from the
right um onethird of those punishments
actually initially start from the right
they're usually enforced by people on
the left but nonethe left less I want
people to be clear this is a book that
takes on both right and left um the and
about almost 200 professors and it will
probably be past that but you know uh by
the uh by the end of this year maybe
this time next year uh were fired and uh
and we also know this a wild undercount
because one in six professors say that
they've been either investigated or
threatened with investigation one in six
have been threatened or investigate
threatened with investigation for for
their academic freedom which is their
free speech their research Etc and about
9% of students say the same thing that
they've been investigated or threatened
with investigation I think actually
investigated for for their free speech
these are amazing numbers but when
people point out it's kind of like oh
well you only document you know about
200 people getting fired I'm like do you
know how many people were fired for
being communists under
McCarthyism uh at the time and we're
still in cancel culture McCarthyism was
11 years and we're and from where we
start we're dealing with about nine and
a half years of data and it's and the
problem seem is is still really quite
bad that if we 62 63 professors were
fired um for being communist about 90
for opinion overall and so the estimate
is usually about 100 were were fired um
we're talking about twice that and in
McCarthyism nobody said that this was
nothing um and the most important thing
for people to know understand about that
is that the law was only established
between between 1957 and 1973 so at the
time that there that these universities
were firing communist professors their
answer was well we can do that they're
incredibly doctrinaire they can't be
allowed to teach in the classroom
they're not critical thinkers they
they're just going to espouse their
political points of view and in 1957 the
court said no you actually can't fire
someone just on the basis of of their
political Viewpoint um and that that
only became clearly established by 1973
so in the past 50 years since the law
has been established there's nothing
even remotely close to the kind of
numbers we're seeing here I mean I
always point out that I started right
around 911 there were three professors
fired after 911 which we considered to
be very bad at the time to be clear but
guess what all three of those were
justified in ways that had nothing to do
with academic freedom or Free Speech one
was gross academic misconduct the other
one was actual ties to International
terrorism and the third one was that
they devoted way too much of their class
to not teaching the subject they were
hired to teach um so the what what I
what has surprised me is the confidence
with which people who don't know a lot
about the history of freedom of speech
think they can evaluate numbers I I
point out that the Sedition Act of 1798
which we consider to be a great stain on
the on the American tradition of freedom
of speech that we uh for all of my life
we thought that that involved about 12
prosecutions we now know it's closer to
50 but still as far as people actually
indict actually who who who were found
guilty I think it's about 10 does that
mean it does doesn't matter no it's
still rightfully considered a great
Scandal
when we look forward there appears to be
uh two groups of people one like
yourself understand what's happening
calling it out ready to um uh do the
work to change and make sure that the
future has more free speech in it has uh
kind of better arguing um and frankly is
probably a better future for our society
yeah there's another group of people who
are like shut up both of you I don't
care this person is an idiot you know
cancel them yeah who wins how how do we
ensure that a certain Viewpoint of free
speech and um you know what I would
consider a respectful discourse and kind
of uh results oriented uh kind of
conversation wins out over cancel
culture and this coddling type mindset
yeah I mean honestly um if you if you
were betting you'd probably bet on a
liberalist
winning uh because I am not seeing the
kind of reflection like self-reflection
on the environment we created over say
like the last six years because cancel
culture really accelerated around 2017
I'm still seeing people claiming that it
didn't even happen I there was an
amazing thing a a um uh a news anchor
Brianna
Joy she um wrote about saying oh no
cancellers were never asking for for
people to get fired the the
accountability culture the
accountability culture people they never
wanted people fired I'm like no they
they demanded people be fired like so so
the the rewriting of history is already
happening and I'm watching people
discover that since people uh can and
will be punished for having Pro
Palestinian points of view I'm reading
all these articles saying oh there's a
new McCarthyism suddenly for the first
time since 911 or even McCarthyism
people are getting in trouble for what
they for their political opinions and
I'm like what where the hell have you
been like this has been a bad a bad
problem for a long time but I thought
maybe this would cause people to go you
know what maybe maybe our whole
accountability culture consequence
culture when one of the consequences is
you losing your job was a little Pat a
little dismissive maybe we should look
at the the recent history of professors
losing their jobs and students being
expelled and people being kicked out of
Journalism publishing Etc um and and
re-evaluate but there seems to be a
determination to just pretend none of
this ever happened so I would say right
now without a lot better appreciation of
how bad it's gotten it's going to keep
getting worse and and these giant um
mega corporations Elite higher education
they are currently saying some of the
right things on on freedom of speech but
they aren't really doing anything that
that that indicates that they're going
to stick with it when uh when the
threats to free speech come from faculty
or students on campus they always circle
the wagons when they think the threat
comes from off campus so there's nothing
surprising there um so I think it's
going to be an uphill battle and we
could use all your listeners
support Greg the book The cancelling of
the American mind uh cancel culture
undermines trust and threatens us all
but there is a solution it's a fantastic
book I've read it uh I actually did not
think that you could uh kind of follow
up the cing of the American mind it's a
a really good book and I really enjoyed
it and I've cited it many times in
private conversation with folks and you
know kind of suggested it to people but
I got to say that uh this this was just
as good if not better um and so anyone
who uh who's interested in this topic
should definitely go and get it um what
what about fire in terms of where can we
send people to learn more about fire uh
especially after they read the book and
and find out more about the work you
guys are doing and and see if it's maybe
something that they want to get involved
with or or figure out way to uh to
support it it's ath fire.org and
definitely check out our campus Free
Speech rankings um we use 13 different
factors to evaluate schools on their
commitment to freedom of speech um you
know including the largest uh survey of
student opinion ever done the four
largest databases of student
cancellations Professor cancellations
deplatforming and speech codes um and
this year we made some Waves by the fact
that Harvard finished dead last which
people occasionally present it as if it
was some kind of stunt like essentially
like oh no no that's exactly where the
data led us so um so I would love that
to be not just 248 schools if we could
do that for say the top 500 schools in
the country that would cover you know a
huge portion of of the fouryear uh
college students in the country
um so yeah we we definitely could use
your support um because unfortunately
the uh the threats to free speech seem
to keep
growing awesome well I appreciate you
taking the time to do this um you know
please write another book I don't know
on what the topic will be but uh but
you're two for two in my book from the
ones that I've read um and and so I look
forward toh to the work that you uh do
next on the book side but also obviously
you guys are fighting the good fight uh
with fire and continue to kind of uh
stand up for those who who maybe don't
have a voice or or need uh need help so
uh very much appreciated and we'll
definitely do this again in the future
absolutely Take Care thank you